[Musique]
nous interrompons cette émission pour une
alerte d'urgence le ministère de la
Défense confirme les rapports d'un
objet inconnu entrant dans l'
atmosphère terrestre l'artefact extraterrestre a atterri sur
terre nous devons savoir pourquoi et ils veulent que
je dirige la mission le voyage est de six
mois si  tout se passe comme prévu
je reviens je vous promets que
c'est la mission la plus importante de l'
histoire de l'humanité il est temps d'
y aller
nous sommes en route vers une planète pleine d'
extraterrestres
j'ai trouvé quelque chose que beaucoup de ces choses
pensez vous sont là
notre premier contact que la
civilisation extraterrestre est un risque que les gens meurent
nous sommes tous ici pour la même raison de
protéger la vie des gens sur
terre attendez qu'est-ce que
vous devez y aller
c'est arrivé ici ça va arriver sur
terre
j'ai  pour sauver l'équipage
st.  terre et
si je peux rencontrer la graine lancer dans
une guerre interstellaire
nous n'avons pas le choix
vous